[Music]
in a world gripped by global pandemic
the brilliant scientists of the cdc are
humanity's last hope from now on i'll be
in charge you've watched them in
contagion and outbreak now see the cdc
as you've never seen them before
accurately it's airborne yeah that's
been obvious for over a year hey cdc my
company is making fast accurate coveted
test kits at very low cost we need to
shut you down this thing's too hot
we can't risk it
yeah from the people who brought you
contradictory mask guidance and told you
to cook your prosciutto the fda has been
sitting on the paperwork for an
effective vaccine that's already
approved in europe we're wasting time
why not r2 about those test kits you
guys developed they're difficult to use
and they're wildly inaccurate any chance
i could start mass producing my cheap
and effective test kits now
no
cool what can the cdc provide to help
sell the public on the lockdown i want
an army of experts citing hundreds and
thousands of lab experiments telling any
idiot with a camera that there was no
other way yeah sure we can do that no
problem can you explain to me why the
centers for disease control is talking
about gun violence
no are you concerned that the cdc faces
a credibility issue here why would you
think that we had any credibility to
begin with in 2014 we told the nurse
with ebola that she could board a
commercial flight from cleveland to
dallas the critics are raving about the
biggest event of the season your website
literally says i'm quoting here
firearm violence is a serious public
health that impacts the health and
safety of americans so i guess my
question is
do you employ copy editors over there no
why did you pause administration of the
johnson and johnson vex because of six
blood clot disorders out of seven
million doses that's less than one in a
million if we're lucky no that's how
math works could you explain why your
budget is 14 times bigger than it was a
few decades ago and yet you were
woefully unprepared for the one thing
you were meant to do no we used data
from a new york times infographic that
was inaccurate it shouldn't be an issue
okay
but we also published our own
infographic with data that was not
statistically significant that's okay
i
don't think it is now you want to tell
people not to get vaccinated and that's
the best chance they've got i wrote on
my blog i think vaccines are great i
just think the mandates are
counterproductive and clearly backfired
i could throw your computer in jail i
would covet ba2
this time
it's more of the same